[Musica]
qua
ecco è stato velamento
e il circe questa è una zucca e line
taglieremo per fare una zucca di
halloween stai fra poco e halloween
nella mia festa preferita vero berlino
e stai perché halloween nella mia testa
preferita sears perché adoro le cose
cosa
hai sentito
marino e sentito
[Musica]
o no non di nuovo
visto anche il tuo circe il lampadario
che si muove hai visto
[Musica]
da minacciare girati
di conoscere i nuovi concorrenti
ho capito forse vitale al piano di sopra
che sto cercando di farmi uno scherzo
vitale che stai facendo e soffitta e
perché stai vivendo sicuramente sta
mangiando qualcosa di nascosto e quindi
si è nascosto in soffitta e sta ridendo
perché è riuscito a nascondersi da me
feroci
vitale guarda che lo so che sei tu
[Musica]
ma mangiando io io io sto mangiando
niente sei salito in soffitta però non
capisco in soffitta che stai dicendo e
poi video devo andare in soffitta
nascondermi per mangiare il manto
benissimo anche di nascosto da un'altra
parte
facciamoci subito un risotto
alla zucca abbiamo o no no si sono
zucche ma sono zucche per l'halloween ok
dobbiamo in tagliarle emettere la
candelina dentro impedirà la si può
mangiare sì sì certo intagliarla ci
pensò di tagliarle poi con l'impegno che
ci faccio sì faccio la torta alla zucca
il risotto alla zucca la crosta dalla
zucca voi tutto con la zucca la
miniserie nascondo che sia almeno sarò
sicura in italia non le cucinerà di
nascosto si può fare un po di tutto con
lo zucchero anche un bel minestrone
andiamo
ti ho detto che quella solo zucche di
halloween non puoi mangiarle e poi non è
sentito con i rumori al piano di sopra
nuovamente o fa voglio mangiare però lo
vedi anche tu che si muove è vero beh sì
la pa dandosi muovere ma si possono fare
tante cose con la zucca pensavo fossi tu
ma se hai detto che tu non eri in
soffitta e qualcos'altro allora
hai sentito sì ho sentito una risata è
la stessa risata che ho sentito primo
sembra che ci sia qualcuno in soffitta
ma no saranno i vicini che stanno
guardando il film comico e per una
risata del film
anzi sembra molto divertente mi sa che
andrò a chiedere il titolo
il titolo come sempre vitale non mi
prende sul serio vi ricordate cosa era
successo chi dice perché vuoi mangiarmi
i capelli c'è solo un modo per scoprirlo
[Risate]
[Musica]
mi aspetta un momento ma vitale è un
sito con la zucca
stare al gioco girardot vitale dove sei
da subito qua
di trovare un altro piano
va bene ne esco permetti lei subito
poggia nel non toccarla più ei va già
contenta devo trovare un piano per
sorvegliare queste zucche adesso perché
sono sicura che vitale proverò a rubarle
di nuovo ea cucinarle a mangiarle
quindi forse le devo nascondere da
qualche parte ma non c'è tempo adesso di
pensare a questo dobbiamo pensare a che
cosa si nasconde in soffitta
hai capito
bene tant'altro abitarla non interessano
mai queste cose ma i dimostrerò che
davvero c'è una voce da so in soffitta è
qualcosa che si muove forse l'unico modo
per dimostrarglielo è andare sopra
soffitta a prendere qualsiasi cosa ci
sia il portargliela mi sembra un ottimo
piano poi questa ne pensate lasciate un
mi piace questo tool per portarmi
fortuna e torniamo in soffitta assieme o
la luce con me così forse riesco a
vedere qualcosa ovviamente ogni volta
che stanco qua in soffitta non si
sentono più i rumori
scherzavo sento dei rumori e ci sono
anche delle luci strane se nessuno e c'è
qualcuno qua
sembra qualcosa che striscia zucca zucca
più che tu
ecco che cos'erano quel rumore che
sentiva la vita
[Musica]
ho sentito delle risate prima c'è
qualcuno che si nasconde nuovamente qua
in soffitta che cosa
lo senti neanche noi questo rumore chi
sei
sei un essere umano
non ha risposta sei un non essere umano
non è un essere umano
di
piccoli che cosa vuoi da noi
forse è meglio tornare al piano di sotto
o almeno avvisare evitare
che cos'è
[Musica]